what's going on everybody we are here at
the Los Angeles Lebowski Fest Coen
Brothers White Russians
the Jesus we're about to get inside this
bowling alley and find out if these
people abide
are you looking forward to anything
specifically here at your first Lebowski
Fest well I like to do to show himself
bridges will not be here
this is Lebowski Fest why are you
dressed as poison ivy from Batman as
soon as I'm off of work I light up the J
and crack up in the half-and-half and my
life just seems all too much better for
that how long have you had a substance
abuse problem after all the bowling and
everything after the last ball comes
from the ball return is there any kind
of Lebowski orgy that's gonna happen
[Music]
not a bad Caucasian yep I've got a Black
Russian myself
hey different strokes for different
folks after the festival there's gonna
be a Lebowski orgy I've had a sweater
vest since I was a preteen what is it
about Lebowski that you love it's just
that kind of movie you can relax and
watch over when you're really hungover
that's exactly what I thought you'll be
watching it tomorrow do you live your
life according to the dudes philosophy
at all that's a yes are there any other
movies that you would go to a fest for
kingpin festival we did a kingpin fest
now so I am here with the man the myth
the legend will Russell who started
Lebowski Fest how did you feel about
them knocking down Hollywood Star Lanes
I think it's a travesty man that's a
real bummer for those who don't know
they knocked down the bowling alley
where Big Lebowski was filmed and they
built what a school a school we don't
need no education we need our Kimbo
lling alley man
[Music]
there was one message to be taken away
from the Big Lebowski what would it be
the dude abides what about something
less cliche
[Music]
Oh guys we came we saw we drank several
right we Came we saw we drank several
White Russians you have a great time
if you were gonna put on the best for a
movie what movie Oh get the [ __ ] out of
the way
what movie would you like to see a fest
foot on for leave us a comment in the
section below best dancer gets a screen
junkies t-shirt I'm Hal Rajnikanth
bye-bye
[Music]